so let's uh we'll let's talk about the
water tag voter integrity project
do you want to just explain what it is
and what you
what you did sure so in the a couple
days after the election
i you know had some ideas about ways to
detect
um potentially illegal ballots i shared
the idea
with a few people privately but it
really no one really took me up on and i
didn't want to even
i initially did not plan to have
anything to do with it was just hey
here's some methods you could use to
potentially detect
illegal ballots and i tweeted about it
and at the time i had like 200 twitter
followers or something
and somebody who followed me who had a
little bit of influence
retweeted it and then somebody else
retweeted it and then it sort of
exploded
and people were saying well you should
set up a gofundme because in the initial
tweet i said
i was probably going to cost about 100k
for just the data to do this
and i said okay fine i set up a gofundme
and uh we raised 220k wow and
within 24 hours and then gofundme shut
the thing down and refunded everybody
their money
whoa they lied to a journalist about why
they shut us down they and i have the
record of this and we may
have more legal matters to discuss can
you tell us why oh sure yeah what they
said was that um
that we were spreading misinformation we
didn't spread it
all we said was like here's some here's
some tests we want to run
and this is what we're going to do with
the money they told a reporter they shut
us down for spreading this information
um so within a few you know i did my
homework we found another
crowdfunding site called give send go i
can't recommend these guys
enough um their rates are very fair
i knew they weren't going to throw us
off um and in fact they don't make money
directly on it it's just that when you
make a contribution to us they ask you
for hey do you want to help us out too
and a lot of people do
um so we were able to raise much more at
when we hit 580
000 whoa i said i said that look
um we've raised enough money to cover
what i think are the expense of this
project
we're not asking for any more money any
money that's left over after we're done
will be returned to donors if they like
it
anybody that's left over after that will
go to a c3
that um a non-profit a non-profit that's
basically about voter registration
fighting potential voter fraud um and
in all those cases no matter where it
goes i'm not personally going to take a
penny of it
um and so but despite that people have
continued to contribute we're all we're
almost a hundred thousand beyond where i
said okay
we have the money to cover this you're
you're looking at uh
doing some tests on whether or not
ballots may be illegal is that fair
that's how we started i built a team of
of a couple of people who are have
similar backgrounds to my own
um and we started obtaining raw voter
data from states we started can you
explain that because
that was crazy to me that you can get
people's information on how they voted
or not how they voted but that they
voted
oh well you can get indications about
how they voted this is yeah
it's too bad i don't have a screen or
something because i can just pop it open
i
i know everything that anybody would
want to know about every voter in this
country
that's at my fingertips it's kind of
creepy that's life and you know it's
also it's kind of unique to the united
states because i've talked about doing
i've talked to
doing political consulting in other
countries it's kind of difficult because
they're very strong privacy laws in
europe et cetera but in the u.s
i know everything a campaign want to
know so in terms of voter contact or
voter analysis it's
it's it's all there and in this case we
were able to attain you know
voter lists from the state states often
release chase files and that means that
every day for like two months leading up
to the election they released the list
of all the people who
uh requested ballots uh or or return
ballots
who showed up to vote early and that's
helpful for campaigns because
if you have like these hundred thousand
people you're trying to reach and turn
out to vote
if the state says okay this person just
voted you can take them off their list
so you're no longer wasting money on
doors phones
mail any social anything else to target
them because you can take them off your
list and focus on the remaining ones
it's called
strike listing so all this is very
useful for that but in this case we
obtained that data to use it to try to
attack detect
potential problems and we used other
government databases to help validate
our methods and to
you know compile our evidence can you
tell us some of these tests what were
you proposing to do
during this original gofundme and this
new kind of fundraiser
well initially we're going to do some
traditional
analysis looking at double voters
looking at people who no longer
had residency looking for potential dead
voters
and and as we got into it we started to
discover
other things other methods that we had
not thought of but then said oh that's
something we should look into
because this is this is unprecedented
you know this has not really been done
before
where you go in depth after an election
because usually after an election the
margin is such that there's no doubt
and nobody's got any money left and
everyone you know honestly it's
thanksgiving
it's christmas time we are unique
because we have this long period between
the election and when the person takes
office now in the uk
day after election they're in and out of
downing street it's like wow that
whereas yeah it's immediate that sounds
terrible
well i think i think it's already bad
enough that we have a couple months
because if you really wanted to do any
kind of hard investigation we don't have
the time to do it
and we have months right well rarely
have we had the need
i think and again it goes back to what i
said that the fundamental problem behind
a lot of this is that
the elect you know there you remember
florida
2000 right nightmare couple hundred
votes nightmare the thing is
i don't think there's any state that
would not be a nightmare
if if the election came down to a couple
thousand votes
and it was very pivotal there's not a
state i think that would
escape finding all kinds of flaws it's
just that those states tend to
they're saved by the victor winning by
enough of a margin that it's like
yes you know no ma the errors and
potential if it existed fraud can't
overcome that margin but here we are
in some of the lawsuits trump presented
the judges have said the amount of bouts
you're questioning would not be enough
to change the outcome therefore
dismissed
i think that's kind of silly because you
add up 10 lawsuits targeting specific
different things
maybe but that's actually been some of
the results yeah that's more
question for the lawyers in terms
because i've seen cases where
actually the um the the number of
questionable ballots
did not have to surpass the margin it
just had to demonstrate some kind of
pattern
and that was enough to get get it thrown
out i think that was the case in miami
when a judge ruled there was voter fraud
down there and threw out a mayor's
election
can you elaborate any more on what the
learned hardy project has done so far or
is that off limits you know i think my
twitter feed's covered extensively but
we found all kinds of
indications of illegal ballots and other
anomalies who presented them on
youtube it's pretty uh i mean we
essentially ran about 38 tests across
six different states
and we put our results out there
publicly um just at this point you know
for the next
short period of time i think it's i've
been encouraged
you know to respect the the litigation
and
we don't want to you know with respect
to the judges involved in this case
i think they would appreciate it if we
weren't you know litigating in public
right but once that's done well you know
we'll crank that laptop up put a
projector up and start
start showing stuff well yeah
within the limits is that i don't want
to um dox anybody yeah
so but there's ways to get around that
um
you know i can uh just just interject
because you know for a lot of people who
are just tuning in
i have uh independently i i guess you
can say independently corroborated
at least well you know i
you i don't know what you can say no you
sides at me and i showed you some things
and you made an evaluation based on that
after i saw it i went and did some
uh general sleuthing and was able to
independently corroborate through
different databases and it was it's very
interesting
more than once so uh i think he found
something i mean i guess we'll see how
it plays out in
the courts but uh i do think it's it's
shocking i mean we
we we kicked off this conversation
reading through you know this response
from these other states saying
that there's no evidence and that to me
is shocking considering i just
corroborated something
i'll put it that way and i corroborated
the corroborators right
can we play a middle ground here and say
how excited
or surprised were you from some of the
findings we don't have to discuss the
findings but
maybe your level of uh excitement or
shock well i'll tell you you know
um i don't think you could i
i was surprised by certain things that i
found
and not surprised by other things uh
i said in on on video without going into
detail that i believe that
in enough states there were enough
potentially legal ballots
to surpass the margins and thus
cast into doubt in my mind whether or
not uh joe biden's the deserved winner
now i've i've said that publicly i don't
have a problem really repeating that
um but there were some things that
decided to be some and
you know not just about the data but
also the process this journey
but we'll clarify too like we're not at
the point where that's definitive it's
just signs and indications perhaps
i i'll save that one for later there you
go all right
where does this go from here what's the
next process what are we waiting for
how is this going to play out well right
now it's
it's in the hands of the lawyers the
judges the legislators
i'm just at the point now where i answer
questions about my findings
and potentially you know answer other
questions as they come up um
so from my perspective the the base
research has been
done and completed we're just you know
giving lawyers affidavits and
declarations and
potentially testifying here and there is
is this in any way related i don't know
feel free to not answer effect if you
can't uh if you can't is this in any way
related to the state's
filing suits um i'm not gonna answer
that
i can't answer that right now but that's
that's this question i'm happy to answer
uh with a brief delay right on well
it's it's it's uh i'm happy you're here
okay but it is you know it's it's
walking a fine line because i'm like
i would uh probably be extremely upset
if something happened from this show you
know in a lawsuit where they're like
we're going to cite you know the tim
castro podcast where matt brainard said
this and then all of a sudden it's like
in case it's missed or something so uh i
guess for the people who are listening i
have no choice
we have no choice but to just try and
you know graze
this as best we can without yeah ruining
everything
i think they i think they support that
too because i'm pretty sure people would
be calling for my head on uh
well i gotta be careful about the
language i use people would be calling
for
uh your beanie and a spike yes my beanie
he had to do this show we're observing
the bannon rule here i see
yes oh definitely man thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you